bienvenidos a washington para este
excepcional episodio de la entrevista de
france 24
eeuu se enfrenta a la crisis sanitaria
más grave de la historia moderna
administración trauma que les recuerdo
va a gobernar el país hasta el 20 de
enero ha sido muy criticada por su
gestión de la crisis y desde ahora es
posible vislumbrar una salida a la
crisis en particular gracias a dos
vacunas diseñadas y producidas por los
laboratorios pfizer y modernas a látex a
la cabeza de la gigantesca operación que
le permitirá la distribución de esta
vacuna no se encuentra un hombre un
científico el doctor hans efe es la web
efe es la wii gracias por haber aceptado
la invitación de france 24 gracias por
invitarme usted es marroquí belga y
estadounidense tiene más de 14 vacunas
en su haber porque aceptó la propuesta
de donald trump de unirse a esta
aventura
realmente la pandemia creó la necesidad
ya en mayo tuvimos un primer pico con si
recuerdo bien más de mil muertes diarias
y también tuvo un impacto enorme en la
vida
por lo tanto a pesar de mi reticencia a
trabajar con esta administración con la
que no estoy en absoluto de acuerdo
decidí que era mucho más importante
ayudar con el descubrimiento el
desarrollo para acelerar todo el proceso
que llevaría a tener la vacuna
hablando concretamente de la operación
rap speed o un programa que permitirá
vacunar rápidamente a los 50 estados de
eeuu cómo se llevará a cabo esta
operación y sobre todo cuáles ciudadanos
se beneficiarán primero de la vacuna
creo que es lógico que las primeras
dosis producidas vayan a los estados que
la financieros pero en cualquier caso
todas las empresas que participaron en
la operación por ejemplo tienen plantas
de fabricación que también fabrican
dosis para el resto del mundo
si calculamos sólo las 6 vacunas que
apoyamos por ejemplo
y si cada una de estas compañías planea
fabricar entre 1 y 2 mil millones de
dosis para el 2021 hasta la primera
mitad de 2022 entonces con seis
compañías diferentes estamos hablando de
más de un billón de unidades
dosis suficientes para vacunar a todo el
mundo
este descubrimiento fue obviamente una
gran apuesta financiera qué piensa de
eso
no estoy convencido de que haya un
beneficio financiero para las empresas
que invirtieron dado que no sabemos
realmente si este virus va a permanecer
mucho tiempo o no y no sabemos si las
vacunas generan una inmunidad a largo
plazo o no por lo que de hecho era
imperativo que a estas empresas se les
diera un apoyo financiero que se les
diera un incentivo para que invirtieran
los recursos que habían invertido en
otras áreas en otras vacunas o en otros
medicamentos
el futuro mostrará si tendremos que
volver a vacunar a la gente una vez al
año si es así será un gran mercado para
obtener ganancias de lo contrario no lo
será si no
son los que creen que el descubrimiento
de esta vacuna la vacuna contra el jove
y 19 es el final de la crisis sanitaria
el descubrimiento es el principio del
final el final será cuando la vacuna sea
usada en todo el mundo por al menos el
80 o el 90 por ciento de la población
mundial para que la circulación del
virus sea realmente eliminada pronto
estarán en circulación varias vacunas lo
que es sorprendente en comparación con
las predicciones iniciales ya que muchos
científicos habían contradicho la
promesa de donald trump de que habría
una vacuna inminente como explica el
hecho de que la investigación se haya
realizado tan rápidamente y lo que es
más importante no le preocupa un poco
era un desafío enorme pero no era algo
imposible si fuera imposible nunca
habría aceptado es muy fácil para muchos
expertos sentarse como espectadores y
criticar decir es imposible así nunca se
resuelven los problemas los problemas se
resuelven cuando pensamos que hay un
camino pero que este tal vez no es
y nos involucramos en buscar la solución
en este caso en particular incluso si
sólo había un 1 por ciento de
posibilidades de éxito teníamos que
intentarlo dado el impacto de esta
pandemia en la población mundial en los
últimos 10 15 años ha habido enormes
investigaciones y grandes progresos en
el desarrollo de lo que llamamos
plataformas tecnológicas para hacer
vacunas sabíamos que podíamos hacer
vacunas muy muy rápidamente que podíamos
predecir cómo se comportaría la
tecnología en términos de si va a ser
seguro para el ser humano la respuesta
inmune que induciría la
industrialización de la producción
podríamos predecir el comportamiento de
todas estas cosas de nuevo a cómo usar
el compost en los dos principales
laboratorios que afirman haber
desarrollado una vacuna hoy en día son
pzifer y modernas
cada uno de esos dos laboratorios
trabajos con una muestra de población de
30 mil individuos cierto moderna con
30.000 y fisher con 44 mil esto es
suficiente no se espera que cuando haya
una vacunación masiva sólo en eeuu
estamos hablando de cientos de millones
de personas no se espera que en ese
momento hay de efectos secundarios
problemas relacionados con el hecho de
que esta vacuna es nueva
no me preocupa que la vacuna tiene
efectos negativos o no porque hemos
utilizado estudios clínicos que son más
grandes que los requeridos por todas las
agencias de medicamentos del mundo
30 a 40 mil personas en lugar de cinco a
seis mil personas no hemos visto ningún
efecto secundario dentro de los 60 días
después de la vacunación sabiendo que el
95 por ciento de todos los efectos
secundarios asociados a una vacuna
ocurren dentro de los 40 días de la
vacunación en tercer lugar hemos
establecido un sistema de
farmacovigilancia que nos permitirá
vigilar muy de cerca a la población
general una vez
la vacuna se utiliza realmente y si hay
algún efecto secundario lo detectaremos
y actuaremos en consecuencia debemos
tener en cuenta dos cosas la primera es
con cuál problema estamos lidiando el
problema con el que estamos lidiando
marca entre 2 a 3 mil personas diarias y
ha afectado completamente la vida social
y económica del mundo y mata a decenas
miles de personas al día en ninguno de
los escenarios imaginables en términos
de los efectos secundarios de la vacuna
se moriría ni siquiera una persona al
día
y si en algún lugar del planeta alguien
se muriera por ser vacunado cuando
podría no haberse muerto de kobe no
podemos descartarlo a nivel individual
es imposible predecirlo no queremos que
suceda pero obviamente es imposible
descartarlo en este contexto también
debemos considerar el beneficio para la
sociedad y el beneficio individual
porque el 99% de las personas vacunadas
se beneficiarán de la vacuna que tiene
una eficacia del 95%
prácticamente una garantía será una de
las primeras personas que se vacunen por
supuesto soy mi familia también cree que
la historia recordará que donald trump
prometió una vacuna muy rápidamente y
que en ese momento no sólo los
científicos sino también los políticos
estadounidenses dijeron que eso no era
cierto y que la vacuna no llegaría hasta
por lo menos dentro de un año
probablemente un año y medio recordemos
a anthony fauci en particular y sus
reservas no esperemos a sus días
plan de seis fases y espero que el mundo
vaya a recordar que la industria
farmacéutica el ecosistema de esta
industria las empresas de biotecnología
el mundo académico la ciencia
permitieron descubrir desarrollar y
producir en tiempo récord vacunas que
van a salvar al mundo y de cierta manera
tenemos suerte de que este virus sólo
maté a uno de cada mil contagiados
la tasa de mortalidad del ébola es del
95 por ciento 7 vídeos fuera como el
evora la catástrofe sería enorme así que
eso es lo que yo espero que la gente
recuerde y que siga apoyando en la
inversión en la investigación científica
porque así es como encontramos
soluciones a problemas como estos
en su opinión pero no como científico
cree que el hecho de que la lucha contra
la pandemia y la búsqueda de una vacuna
de que se haya convertido en una batalla
política en un momento muy excepcional
de la vida política de eeuu en medio de
las elecciones
ha sido bueno o malo para la
investigación
me preocupaba mucho me sigue preocupando
la politización lo que pasó con todo
este asunto de hecho eso creó una
atención y una pérdida de confianza
entre la población en general porque el
riguroso trabajo científico que se
estaba llevando a cabo se confundía con
el discurso político de los dos bandos
cuando decía es imposible no podemos
hacerlo hay algo sospechoso y el otro
decía vamos a hacerlo antes de las
elecciones pienso que ambos estaban
equivocados asustaron a la población
nosotros hicimos todo lo posible para
mantenernos al margen de todas estas
cuestiones y debates políticos y espero
que ahora que los datos se van a hacer
públicos la gente tendrá la oportunidad
de escuchar a las personas en las que
confía
que lleguen a la conclusión de que
estaba unas son seguras arribar a la
conclusión que se basan son
seif quiere que la industria
farmacéutica y los gobernadores van a
aprender de esta pandemia
eso es pero la forma de prepararse es
contar con instituciones permanentes
cuyo objetivo sea investigar desarrollar
y fabricar un millón de dosis vacunas
contra todos los virus que sabemos que
tienen el potencial de ser virus
pandémicos cuáles son las ventajas de
tener una institución como ésta en
primer lugar podría ser que una de las
vacunas que fabricamos sea la vacuna
contra el próximo virus pandémico por lo
que ya tendríamos una ventaja o
alternativamente si es un nuevo virus
tendremos una infraestructura industrial
capaz de trabajar en este nuevo virus
capable y trabajar más rápido con menos
disrupciones que antes y ser capaces de
fabricar vacunas igual de rápido sino
más rápido
una organización de ese tipo podría
costar 100 150 millones de dólares por
año en esta saga estamos 12 mil millones
de dólares
aunque en cuánto tiempo después de la
vacunación del último ciudadano
estadounidense veremos la vacunación de
los parecidos de los habitantes de
casablanca y de los de formosa
francamente empezaría antes de que
terminaremos de vacunar aquí porque
tenemos fábricas que elaboran vacunas
para todo el mundo de hecho hemos
invertido en validar la tecnología
validar las formas en que se fabrica
etcétera para exportar la vacuna
mientras estamos fabricando aquí para
eeuu exportarla a otros lugares para ser
producida para los países europeos y
para el resto del mundo
creo que hay una gran conciencia del
hecho de que todos los seres humanos
deben ser vacunados para controlar esta
pandemia y vacunar a todos los seres
humanos terminamos con estas palabras
muchas gracias por recibirnos doctor
están en france 24 que desee con
nosotros
[Música]